so what mom left me is family me you
know it's nothing to pay to get in this
pool
did you ever need religion in your life
did you need to Islam so leaving it's no
big deal
it was nothing really
that was never understood either I don't
see a vein and then I was forced to play
when you know it's too cold when I was
finished when I was forced to play mean
you know I was playing an Arabic that
was [__] getting that's all this
time and I hope you life is not a
problem the problem was what you endured
while you were living under the
influence of Islam I talked about that
you know you got a lot of things women
seen this as Lamas not a problem and
it's cultured and and it's all this
nonsense and I think the women the women
might see that as well as not building
problem that is why I was wonderful and
I think Joe that's key that's absolutely
brilliant but think about your sisters
and as well do something a woman's that
are
possibilities women that are forced into
marriage forced into marriage with a
complete suite I mean be you know as
well maybe what the [__] new life and
that's great there's not really a that's
wonderful just a very fortunate day
you'd be coordinates a family they get
should be done but as well you want to
go further there's so many women and men
and children without a place you can
also say you know a lot of religions
could be a player stuff like that was
talked about honor killings and machine
culture in Ireland and the women in
Germany suffer but that's not M
textually or structurally mind is it
last question
[Music]
become Christians and their life is
absolutely no and mrs. TPP so to save it
it happens in other cultures and other
religions what it does but Islam how
long have you been free from well yeah
and I know that you live them under the
feet of death I know that but when did
you where would you say you've
consciously left Islam scented by to
[__] you
no more Celia I don't even know this
before the internet could be the
database well I did what was possible to
leave Islam I didn't know about of
course to see or not all of this and it
was the end to me being able to see sea
urchin and find out things in and you
are united to all the sea for the
longest time I used to see out on this
one just not very good one
okay have fun Allah you know all the
things that I am the move is a skip way
cuz I've been in solitary journey you
went from an affluent part of Glasgow to
essentially a [__]
with us as a single mother but a child
to look after so that must have been you
quickly go so as if that ever been you
know looking back because it was such a
long time ago but looking back and I
think that all those nights of feeling
would live its loneliness that really
really gets to you because you come from
my future today with family you'll never
really get to spend any time on your own
to then be alone a is the best thing
that ever happened to me you know
looking back on that thing everything
everything was so worth it to be feeling
to be able to you know selling things to
be able to feel the words of my here to
get to be the son
be able to last all my life to be able
to meet possessions my you intercessions
whether they're right whether they're
wrong they're my decisions
so then essentially you're lucky because
you have the strength of character to
come away from an abusive situation some
people don't have and you're no fun to
reach out and help people extend your
arm to say hey I'm here for you and for
the longest time up in Seattle sex
mascara because that just feel like it's
another label to go on to the Buddhist
or our next phase and all these labels
labels labels and the reason I am I'm
close to see Amex in this room I'm a
paucity is to give those that are still
suffering that are still struggling and
do you feel that the I know that
politically you're not far right I know
that for a fact
to my dear friend but do you think the
right are using you as their token
Muslim because you know they've always
got a token black a token Muhammad's our
token this and that's what people view
you are do you feel that I can see that
I'm using the far right because delay or
ungodly don't get me a platform you did
or anything in the story they're the
ones are calling me a Nazi Hitler thesis
baguette ashes all more labels I know
that M politics isn't as long as it
isn't part of the school system I know
that you not political animal you were
there to reach out to encourage
ex-muslims to come forward that's lesson
sense of what you are you're not the
other far-right of our letter and just
really to say in LA on the harmful
practices that Warren and
see that those that have Rebecca foisted
me high-profile Muslims that have a much
much better voice than me that are
silent they're silent about all these
issues that they want us to believe that
as long as wonderful as far as pieces
why does tell mama hit you party noted
liar see as Miguel yeah actually I told
you why does he hit you
why is it always shut you down on
Twitter why do the D platform you why
don't they reach out to you and say this
is fantastic huge help because they
don't warn the outside community didn't
want the provider community to know what
was on in their community they want us
to thank that Muslims are wonderful and
Islamic peaceful doodle-oo Muslims are
wonderful there's wonderful Muslims the
world over there's wonderful Muslims and
my own family that's wonderful Muslims
everywhere but then it doesn't take away
from the fact that Islam is still evil I
know that you're speaking at the
veterans an event and you're going to be
sharing your story of your forced
marriage and what went on within that
marriage joined to give us a lot teaser
theater you know the man into thing is
fairly people will see all she says bad
things about Islam because her family
were bad and they posted in tamales I'm
not the only girl in the world that's
before since I managed the world over
again you know this is culture so
America losing each other people's
entomology skelos Tunisia Libya garrison
entire girls in Pakistan in Tunisia what
connects all the walls Islam it's not
our culture's our houses are fast buried
is SRAM techniques
and you if I try to explain so you meet
somebody on your way tonight
that's person you meet that person on
your way tonight it's a looker no
disrespect German I'm not really be
nasty about his looks are a number like
that
but even you know able to walk past him
in this G it's not sometimes even a good
time never be it's absolutely nothing in
common we were pulled so far he was much
older he just wants definitely sir he
wasn't interested to me you know my mom
always used to say to me they you learn
to love people to love you you'll fall
in love the famous game which is the
fact available share ever there's
absolutely not been informing her a
virtually yummy really change those
really immature Stella a and he was just
so much altered and enter politics then
I want to watch doctor person and to
have to see that be as nice question you
those no physical attraction or some
emotional connection there was nothing
how does it feel to be touched by
someone that you didn't know what to
touch it
I've been for the longest I smelled a
before I made myself look as ugly as
possible oven or shoving Homer here with
much more fees thinking if I just looked
weird smell bad you want to talk about
the hospitalizations our weekly to the
veterans to the veterans
okay guys are the loss to come up on the
Veterans Day keep the state's watching
and wails about this London it's just
about to be one and a half minute little
snippets we get to them two minutes
that's not if you thought of nothing
else and so you even hear the better man
it's not like but industry's feeling in
force entomology and having to to [__]
up AIDS but some of the day that you
have no feelings for and to be so the
time in my life where I feel really
suicidal I don't know I love was going
to commit suicide but the thoughts were
always there that I would prepare an off
day they feel easier and have to be
called
yes saying nothing and one of the main
reasons that a speaker because I'm not
that person anymore
you know up Oh Stella fakes you you can
never ever get away from that pastel
stockholder and Tennessee I struggled
with relationships there's loads of
issues that I have around having to go
to about an annual the row anthe in Adam
take control and make choices for my own
life there are so many ghettos at
fifteen or sixteen being taken out of
school and be forced to Molly first
president strangers and what sort of
place for you to go over those over MIT
was the women's shelters the city lights
out Branson or sometimes was anything
help for you nothing I wasn't extra
selfie too much nothing feels still
really want to feed more spoon I would
still see I was Muslim well hold your
family around can you let that marriage
though and so where did you go be on the
street
I mean solution and then to the homeless
women if it means watch work happy any
child average I don't my cleaver eme
charlie is I thank you replenish you
know so this would just all and be any
charities then keep you isolated so you
still and not community that community
then the looks doughnut smells at you
because your photos I'm not sure what
it's like no I'm pretty sure it's not
change that much saying but backing
you know you've got Shane went to the
community you've walked out of a
marriage it's raining in London and your
disciplines and how does that feel - my
dad he's my dad you know so even though
we didn't have enough tacos I struggled
from Romania many years thinking that
effort is that he may you know he may
forget me and I obvious obvious alcohol
and people don't understand right people
would say to me off just for your dad is
your dad just hold on to be silly you
know all that calm and they don't
understand that whole culture thing and
vendeur disorders by your family
plaintiff to survey the entire community
because my dad destroy me so I've been a
spy from his fear if I they make sunny
versus a lot of acceptance or a lot of
familiarity in stage I had to see a
whole new way and the trashy community
business my dad is reason to believe
that way people were trash and resent me
and my reality was and my experience was
with white people see beyond my
Pakistani Todd white people accept me as
one of their own a newly accept I'm I'm
really well really small [__] and
Pakistani community they're all we ever
seen yes the girls daughter